hey everybody welcome back to Simply
learn YouTube channel today we are
taking a closer look at a job that many
of us may not be too familiar with the
business analyst this job can be complex
and dynamic and it's definitely worth
diving into to see what they do and how
much they earn so who is a business
analyst anyway well to put it simply
they're the ones who figure out how a
business can make the most money
possible they dig into data and
analytics to find out what's working and
what's not and come up with solutions to
help business grow but that's just a
general overview let's take a closer
look at different types of business
analysts out there for example there are
Financial analysts who specialize in
Finance and Accounting there are also
marketing analysts who specialize in
marketing and sales and let's not forget
about data analysts they are the ones
who delve into the numbers and come up
with insights that help business make
better decisions but wait there's more
there are even it business analysts who
help companies manage their ID systems
and if you are really interested in Tech
they this might be a good career path
for you now let's talk about how much
business analysts make according to
Glassdoor the average salary for a
business analyst varies based on
experience and location but on an
average a business analyst can make
anywhere from fifty thousand dollars to
hundred thousand dollars per year that's
pretty impressive considering the fact
that many of these jobs don't require a
specific degree in business in fact many
businesses will train you on the job if
you have experience in related field so
if you want to learn more about the
intricacies of a business analyst role
and how you can become one then stay
tuned with us until the end of this
video as we discuss everything about
business analyst right from their role
to their salaries so without any further
Ado let's jump in but wait if you want
to embark on a journey as a business
analyst then simply learns postage
program and business analysis can help
you gain the skills and experience you
need to success in this Dynamic field
this program is designed to provide a
comprehensive understanding of business
analysis including data analysis
business process modeling and project
management the program is delivered
through a combination of online courses
live instruction-led classes and
Hands-On projects you can work on real
world business problems and gain
practical experience this program is
also designed to help you prepare for
industry certifications including the
certified business analysis professional
or insured cbap so if you're ready to
take your career to the next level and
become a business analyst enroll in
simpler's postgraduate program and
business analysis today with simply
learn you can learn anytime anywhere and
at your own pace the link to the course
will be added in the description box
below so make sure you check that out
so what is business analysis business
analysis is being like a detective for a
company it helps a company figure out
what it needs and how to make things
better business analysis is done for all
sort of things a company wants to do
whether big or small
it can be part of a specific project or
ongoing as a company grows and improves
of it as this way business analysis
helps a company understand where it is
right now where it wants to go and how
to get it there it's like looking at a
map and planning the best route for the
journey it's essential because it helps
the company make smart decision and find
ways to create value for the people
involved so if you are into solving
mystery and helping company grow
business analysis might be the perfect
role for you till now you must have
gotten an idea of what business analysis
is now we will see who is a business
analyst a business analysis is a person
who performed business analysis Stars
described in a book of b a b o k which
is the business analysis body of
knowledge
no matter their job title or
organization role business analysts are
responsible for discovering and
analyzing information for various
sources within an Enterprise including
tools processes documentation and
stakeholders
now let's see what business analysts do
the activity that business analysts
perform includes business analysts
understand Enterprise problem and goals
analyze needs and solutions performing
strategies Drive change and facilitate
stakeholder collaboration moving ahead
with the position that we are have in
the business let's begin with discus the
typical salary range for entry-level
business analyst position it's important
to keep in mind that salary figures
depend on various factors such as
location industry company size however
we can provide a general idea of what
you might expect
but before that let me tell you what is
the role of a business analyst
it is a job role in which a person
analyze the business model of a company
for decision making
elicitating requirements and using those
requirements to get clients on board and
understanding what the client really
wants is one of the most significant
responsibilities of ba business analysts
typically take the lead role in
assisting with the business cases
planning and monitoring illustrating
requirements gathering information and
requirements requirements organization
translating and simplifying requirements
requirements management and
communication and the last is
requirements analysis
for entry-level business analyst or
associate business analyst in the U.S
the salary range for an entry-level
business analyst is approximately
between 50 000 US dollar to seventy
thousand US dollar per annum and in
India the salary for an entry-level
business analyst is typically between 3
lakh to six lakh per annum now in the
U.S the salary range for a business
analyst of senior role is typically
between 70 to 100 000 US dollar per
annum and for senior level business
analyst in India the salary range can be
between 6 to 12 lakh per annum now let's
see the lead business analyst profile in
the U.S the salary range for a lead
business analyst is typically between
100 000 US dollar to 150 000 US dollar
per annum and the salary range for lead
business analyst in India can vary from
12 lakh banana to 25 lakh per annum now
everyone processes at their own pace
based on their skills opportunities and
Industry demand keep seeking
professional development take on
challenging tasks and build strong
relationship with them to accelerate
your growth as a business analyst now
let's discuss Industries where a beer
role is required business analysts work
in different Industries such as Finance
banking Insurance Telecom utilities
software Services government Etc due to
working on projects at a responsible
high level of abstraction ba can switch
between any of all industry finally
business analysts do not have a
predefined and fixed role as they can
participate in operational scaling sales
planning strategy or the development
process
so are you ready to embark on the
journey as a business analyst start
building your foundation sharpen your
skills and gain hands-on experience be
the detective who uncovers insight and
help businesses thrive the world of
business analyst awaits you and remember
simply learn postgraduate program in
business analysis can provide you with
the comprehensive skills and knowledge
you need to succeed in this field
take the leap and unlock your potential
as a business analyst now go out there
and solve mystery Drive Challenge and
become the hero that businesses need the
career as a business analyst is waiting
for you so with this we have read the
end of this video make sure to like and
share this video And subscribe to Simply
learns YouTube channel thank you
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign